INTO THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
KEEPING TRACK OF ALL OF IT
TONIGHT, CHIEF WHITE HOUSE
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS ON THE NORTH LAWN.
>> IS THE PRESIDENT WAS LEAVING
THIS AFTERNOON TO GO TO
SAN DIEGO, HE SAID HE IS NEARLY
GOT THE CABINET AND STAFF WERE
HE WANTS IT WHICH IS AN
INDICATION THERE MAY STILL BE
SOME CHANGES AHEAD.
ONE OF THE POTENTIAL CHANGES
THAT COULD BE HAPPENING,
ACCORDING TO THE
ASSOCIATED PRESS, TRADING OUT
SECRETARY SHULKIN AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF VETERAN AFFAIRS
FOR RICK PERRY.
THE PRESIDENT IS A BIG FAN OF
RICK PERRY.
DAVID SHULKIN HAS RUN INTO
PROBLEMS, CONTROVERSY OVER
TRAVEL.
THE PRESIDENT WOULD LIKE TO PUT
RICK PERRY WITH HIS LONG TRACK
RECORD OF HELPING VETERANS INTO
A POSITION LIKE THAT.
AS TO WHAT HAPPENED TODAY, WE
FIRST REPORTED THE LIKELIHOOD
THAT THIS WAS GOING TO HAPPEN TO
YOU LAST FALL, THAT IS GETTING
RID OF REX TILLERSON AND PUTTING
IN MIKE POMPEO.
FIVE MONTHS AFTER WE FIRST
REPORTED IT, FINALLY HAPPENED
THIS MORNING.
BUT IT WAS NOT A SURPRISE.
IT HAD BEEN RUMORED FOR MONTHS.
BUT THE SUDDEN ANNOUNCEMENT THAT
SECRETARY OF STATE REX TILLERSON
WAS FIRED SENT SHOCK WAVES
THROUGH WASHINGTON.
>> WE GOT ALONG QUITE WELL.
BUT WE DISAGREED ON THINGS.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE IRAN DEAL.
I THINK IT'S TERRIBLE.
I GUESS HE THOUGHT IT WAS OKAY.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP MADE THE
DECISION LAST WEEK.
WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS SAY CHIEF
OF STAFF JOHN KELLY CALLED
TILLERSON WHO WAS TRAVELING IN
AFRICA ON FRIDAY TO TELL HIM HE
WOULD HAVE TO STEP ASIDE.
OFFICIALS SAY TILLERSON ASKED
KELLY IF THE PRESIDENT WOULD
WAIT UNTIL HE RETURNED.
TILLERSON TOUCHED DOWN IN D.C.
AT 4:00 A.M. TODAY.
FIVE HOURS LATER,
PRESIDENT TRUMP TWEETED:
"MIKE POMPEO, DIRECTOR OF THE
CIA, WILL BECOME OUR NEW
SECRETARY OF STATE.
HE WILL DO A FANTASTIC JOB!
THANK YOU TO REX TILLERSON FOR
HIS SERVICE!"
>> I WISH REX A LOT OF GOOD
THINGS.
>> MEETING THE PRESS THIS
AFTERNOON, TILLERSON DID NOT
SOUND HAPPY IN THE LEAST.
>> I RECEIVED A CALL TODAY FROM
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES A LITTLE AFTERNOON
TIME FROM AIR FORCE ONE.
WHAT IS MOST IMPORTANT IS TO
ENSURE AN ORDERLY AND SMOOTH
TRANSITION DURING A TIME OF THE
COUNTRY CONTINUES TO FACE
SIGNIFICANT POLICY AND NATIONAL
SECURITY CHALLENGES.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE AS THE TIMING
WAS DRIVEN IN PART BY LAST
WEEK'S ANNOUNCEMENT OF A
POSSIBLE MEETING BETWEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
NORTH KOREA'S KIM JONG UN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WANTED A NEW
TEAM IN PLACE FOR THAT PROCESS
AND THE NUMEROUS TRADE DEALS THE
PRESIDENT WANTS TO RENEGOTIATE.
AND HE SIMPLY LOVES MIKE POMPEO.
>> TREMENDOUS ENERGY, TREMENDOUS
INTELLECT.
WE ARE ALWAYS ON THE SAME
WAVELENGTH.
THE RELATIONSHIP HAS BEEN VERY
GOOD.
THAT'S WHAT I NEED A SECRETARY
OF STATE.
>> TILLERSON'S FIRING PROMPTED
SWIFT REACTION.
>> WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP DID AND
THE WAY HE DID IT ONCE AGAIN
INDICATES THE CHAOS IN THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
I'VE NEVER SEEN A PRESIDENTIAL
ADMINISTRATION SO BASICALLY
DISORGANIZED, AT WAR WITH ONE
ANOTHER.
CREATING HUGE PROBLEMS FOR THE
COUNTRY.
>> TO REPLACE BOBBIO AT CIA,
PRESIDENT TRUMP CHOSE CAREER CIA
OFFICIAL GINA HASPEL.
SHE WOULD BE THE FIRST WOMAN TO
LEAD THE SPY AGENCY.
HASPEL'S SENATE CONFIRMATION IS
DRAWING FIRE OVER HER
INVOLVEMENT IN CIA BLACK SITE
OPERATIONS.
>> HAD A GOOD WORKING
RELATIONSHIP.
RIGHTFULLY THERE ARE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS TO BE ASKED.
>> FILLING THE POSITION OF CHIEF
ECONOMIC ADVISOR GARY COHN IS
ALSO ON THE PRESIDENT'S MIND,
THE PRESENT REVEALING LARRY
KUDLOW IS A LEADING CANDIDATE.
>> I HAVE KNOWN HIM A LONG TIME.
WE DON'T AGREE ON EVERYTHING BUT
IN THIS CASE I THINK IT'S GOOD.
I WANT DIVERSE OPINIONS.
HE HAS COME AROUND TO BELIEVING
IN TARIFFS.
>> ALL OF THIS AS
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS HEADING TO
FOR A BORDER WALL.
>> IF YOU DIDN'T HAVE WALLS OVER
HERE, YOU WOULDN'T EVEN HAVE A
COUNTRY.
BY THE WAY, THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS BEGGING US TO
BUILD WALLS IN CERTAIN AREAS.
THEY DON'T TELL YOU THAT.
SPEAK OF THE PRESIDENT FAVORS A
WALL WITH THE SEE-THROUGH
COMPONENTS OF BORDER TROLL CAN
KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON.
HIS PROBLEM: DEMOCRATS CONTINUE
TO REFUSE TO GIVE HIM THE MONEY
TO BUILD IT.
ONE OTHER STAFF CHANGE AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THIS IS A BIT OF A SURPRISE
ITSELF.
HAPPENED YESTERDAY.
THE PRESIDENT'S SO-CALLED BODY
MAN, FORMER UCONN CORNERBACK
JOHNNY MACK TEEN WAS LET GO AND
ESCORTED FROM THE GROUNDS OF THE
WHITE HOUSE.
DETAILS SURROUNDING HIS
DEPARTURE REMAIN MURKY THOUGH HE
DID ALMOST IMMEDIATELY LAND A
JOB AT THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
ELIJAH CUMMINGS, DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSMAN, WANTS ANSWERS AND